Merry Christmas.
How's your leg?
Very good, thanks for asking. Come on in.
Oh! Good, Penny, you're here to exchange gifts.
You'll be pleased to know I'm prepared for whatever you have to offer.
Okay, here.
I should note, I'm having some digestive distress...
...so if I excuse myself abruptly, don't be alarmed.
Oh! A napkin.
Turn it over.
"To Sheldon, live long and prosper. Leonard Nimoy".
He came into the restaurant. Sorry the napkin's dirty. He wiped his mouth with it.
I possess the DNA of Leonard Nimoy?!
Well,...
...yeah, yeah, I guess. But look, he signed it.
Do you realize what this means?
All I need is a healthy ovum and I can grow my own Leonard Nimoy!
Okay, all I'm giving you is the napkin, Sheldon.
Be right back.